[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance elle
a été distribuée nous n'avons pas ce
refus d'observation même si j'ai deux
rappels de mise au point mais
qui j'aurai la parole dans quelques
instants s'il n'y a pas d'autres
observations ne procès verbal est
adoptée sous des réserves d'usagé
mais au poil le président claude
malhuret président du groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
souhaité faire une mise au point sur un
vote merci
cette rectification lors du scrutin
public de ce numéro 120 du 20 juillet
2022 hier soir les sénateurs mélo
medevielle vermeulen capus paoli gage un
grand ainsi que moi-même souhaitions
nous abstenir et le sénateur lagourgue
souhaitez voter contre
un acte de cette demande
madame nicole duranton merci monsieur le
président rectification de vote
également sur le scrutin numéro 120 sur
l'article 2 du projet de loi maintenant
provisoirement un dispositif de veille
et de sécurité sanitaire en matière de
lutte contre la copie 19 marie laure
phinéra horth souhaite s'abstenir
nous donnons acte cette mise au point
ces deux mises au point seront publiés
au journal officiel et figure au dans
l'analyse politique du scrutin
l'ordre du jour mes chers collègues
appellent la discussion du projet de loi
autorisant la ratification du protocole
au traité de l'atlantique nord sur
l'accession de la république de finlande
la ratification du protocole au même
traité sur l'accession du royaume de
suède la procédure accélérée a été
engagée sur ce texte dans la discussion
générale je vais donner la parole à
madame catherine colonna minnis de
l'europe aidée à fait à étrangères
madame la ministre
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur ces présidents cambon
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis honorée de présenter
aujourd'hui au sénat le projet de loi
visant à autoriser la ratification des
deux protocole au traité de l'atlantique
nord sur l'accession de la république de
finlande et du royaume de suède
vous mesurez comme moi je le sais
l'importance de ces deux textes et jeté
à vous remercier d'avoir permis leur
examen rapide malgré l'agenda
particulièrement lourd qui est le vôtre
les demandes d'adhésion formulée par
stockholm et par helsinki constitue une
évolution historique pour ces deux pays
attachez traditionnellement à des
politiques de non participation à des
alliances militaires pour la suède il
s'agit d'une rupture avec près de deux
siècles d'une neutralité décidée suite
au conflit qui avait opposé la suède et
la norvège en 1814 pour la finlande
cette décision tourner la page des
premières heures de la guerre froide et
de la neutralité forcée imposée par
l'union soviétique en 1948
difficile à envisager il ya encore six
mois ces deux mondes sont la conséquence
directe de l'évolution de notre
environnement de sécurité provoquée par
l'agression militaire de la russie
contre l'ukraine depuis le 24 février
ces demandes sont le fruit de décision
souveraine prise a dit sue d'importants
travaux de consultation nationale et
internationale reflétant des évolutions
majeures de l'opinion publique dans
chacun de ces deux pays
je signale au demeurant que la finlande
et la suède avait déjà adapté leur
politique de défense et la suite de
l'annexion de la crimée et de la
déstabilisation du dombass en 2014 et
plus généralement dans le contexte
marqué par une posture russe de plus en
plus menaçante est de plus en plus
agressive
ces demandes répondent à un besoin de
sécurité accrue de la suède et de la
finlande en devenant les 31e et 32e
membres de l'alliance atlantique
ces deux alliés pourront bénéficier du
principe fondateur de l'alliance qu'ils
aient l'obligation d'assister en cas d'
attaques armées contre l'un de ses
membres
obligation inscrite à l'article 5 du
traité de l'atlantique nord
ces adhésions constitueront également un
gain pour la sécurité de l'espace
baltique et pour la sécurité collective
des européens en effet la suède comme la
finlande dispose de capacités militaires
robuste qui contribueront
significativement à la sécurité de
l'ensemble des alliés l'armée
finlandaise compte parmi les plus
fournis d'europe en matière d'effectifs
et d'artillerie
la suède qui entretient une industrie de
défense compétitive un an annoncé de son
côté une importante revalorisation de
son budget de défense pour atteindre
bientôt les 2% du produit intérieur brut
toutes deux sont dotés de capacités et
d'équipements qui sont déjà commun de
nombreux alliés permettant ainsi une
parfaite interopérabilité au sein de
l'otan je signalerai en doute que la
france a pu voir à l'oeuvre et apprécier
les capacités suédoises et finlandaises
dans le cadre de la participation active
d'helsinki et de stockholm à la
politique de sécurité et de défense
commune de l'union européenne dans des
zones prioritaires pour nos intérêts la
suède notamment activement contribué à
la task force d'aqoba de 2020 cette
année au sahel et depuis 2013 à la
mission intégrée des nations unies pour
la stabilisation au mali la minus main
de son côté la finlande participent à la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali untm mali et à la
minus main
par ailleurs l'engagement ces deux pays
pour la défense européenne ne fait aucun
doute en témoigne leur participation à
l'initiative européeenne d'intervention
dit et eux ils dont la principale
vocation est de faire émerger une
culture stratégique et opérationnelle
commune aux européens
enfin et c'est un point fondamental
l'adhésion de la suède la finlande
renforcera la place des européens dans
l'alliance atlantique en portant à 23 le
nombre d'états membres de l'union
européenne au sein de l'alliance ces
adhésions consolideront l'otan elle-même
mais aussi son pays et européens
cela aura également un effet bénéfique
pour l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne c'est à dire sa capacité à
assurer elles mêmes la défense de ses
propres intérêts de sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs une ambition de plus en
plus assumé par ses états membres comme
le montre la décision récente du
danemark soutenu par voie de référendum
par plus de 66 % de sa population de
s'intégrer désormais pleinement à la
politique européenne de sécurité et de
défense commune
l'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
confortera en outre les choix
stratégiques c'est par de nombreux états
membres qui à la suite notamment du
sommet de versailles en mars dernier ont
décidé de réinvestir dans leur défense
et je précise qu'il ne s'agit pas de
compétition entre organisations mais
bien d'un vaste mouvement de réveil
stratégique de la part de nos
partenaires mouvement qui bénéficiera
tant à l'otan que l'union européenne à
notre sécurité collective européennes et
transatlantiques et donc à la sécurité
de la france et des français
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames dessinatrice
messieurs les sénateurs il est
fondamental que nous soyons au rendez
vous de ce mouvement de ce moment
historique pour la sécurité européenne
c'est notre responsabilité et c'est
notre responsabilité à plusieurs égards
tout d'abord vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de
nos alliés dans les chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement soutenu à l'unanimité les
candidatures de stockholm et helsinki
lors du sommet de l'otan à madrid le 29
juin dernier
comme vous vous en souvenez cette
unanimité a été difficile à obtenir en
raison des réserves d'un allier nature
qui au motif affiché de différends
bilatéraux en particulier avec la suède
concernant la lutte contre le pkk
ses réserves ont été levées à la faveur
d'un mémorandum d'entente avec la
finlande et la suède conclu par la
turquie avec ces deux pays en marge du
sommet je précise cependant que si ce
mémorandum a eu le mérite de lever les
réserves turques il ne constitue en rien
un engagement de nature alliés de l'otan
ni l'ensemble de ses membres
cet accord ouvert la voie le 5 juillet à
bruxelles à la signature des protocoles
d'adhésion par la suède la finlande
ainsi que les représentants permanents
des 30 alliés auprès de l'otan la phase
de ratification par les 30 alliés selon
le droit interne de chacun est ouverte
depuis lors plusieurs d'entre eux ayant
eu recours à des procédures accélérées
ce qui sait qu'à ce jour 18 alliés 18
sur 30 ont déjà ratifié les protocoles
parmi lesquels le canada le royaume uni
et nombre de pays européens dont
l'allemagne ou encore la pologne aux
etats unis les deux textes ont été
approuvés par la chambre des
représentants et sont désormais soumis à
l'examen du sénat et ce matin alors que
je m'apprêtais à vous dire que dix
ateliers avaient ratifié les protocoles
la belgique vient d'achever son
processus de ratification portant ce
nombre donc à 18
en france le projet de loi autorisant la
ratification de ces deux protocoles
d'adhésion est examiné par le conseil
d'état le 12 juillet puis en conseil des
ministres le 13 il est désormais soumis
à votre approbation
c'est ensuite notre responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos compétiteurs et rivaux
stratégique
jusqu'à leur adhésion effective
stockholm et helsinki ne seront pas
formellement couverte par l'article 5 et
pourraient être exposés à des actions de
provocation de déstabilisation conduite
par des pays hostiles cet élargissement
dont ils perçoivent bien qu'il réduira à
terme leur marge de manoeuvre et leurs
moyens de pression
nous avons d'ailleurs fait part de notre
disposition à apporter des mesures de
réassurance pour cette période
intermédiaire si la finlande et la suède
le souhaitent
par ailleurs et comme le président de la
république l'a rappelé ces deux pays
bénéficie bien sûr de la clause
d'assistance mutuelle de l'article 42
paragraphe 7 du traité sur l'union
européenne
il en va enfin et peut-être
surtout de notre responsabilité à
l'égard de nos concitoyens dans la
sécurité est notre priorité
nous pourrons assurer encore plus
efficacement leur sécurité en renforçant
notre sécurité collective
la france participe pleinement depuis
2014 et plus encore depuis le 24 février
dernier au renforcement de la posture de
l'alliance sur le flanc oriental elle
participe à la présence avancée de
l'otan en roumanie en tant que nation
cadre et les présente également en
estonie elle contribue aux opérations de
police du ciel et de surveillance
maritime dans l'espace considérer
ainsi comme l'a dit le président de la
république nous devons être au rendez
vous d'histoire en menant à bien le
processus de ratification de ces deux
protocoles
enfin je rappellerai que les
dispositions de ces deux textes sont
pleinement compatibles avec d'une part
les engagements pris par la france dans
le cadre des nations unies article 2
articles 51 de la charte de l'autre avec
ses engagements dans le cadre de l'union
européenne le traité sur l'union
européenne article 42 7 que je
mentionnais il ya quelques instants
renvoie effectivement aux engagements
souscrits par les états membres dans le
cadre de l'otan ainsi la ratification du
protocole de ces deux protocoles ne
nécessitera tel pas de modification du
droit français ou l'adoption de
dispositions législatives ou
réglementaires nouvelles
qu'elles sont mais c'est le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs les
principales observations capelle le
projet de loi visant à autoriser la
ratification du protocole au traité de
l'atlantique nord sur l'accession de la
république de finlande et la
ratification du protocole au traité de
l'atlantique nord sur l'accession du
royaume de suède aujourd'hui proposer à
votre approbation je vous remercie
merci
je vais maintenant donner la parole aux
présidents christian cambon rapporteur
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées
je suis président
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
qui aurait cru il ya seulement six mois
que nous serions appelé à débattre de
l'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
à l'otan si nous en avions besoin voilà
bien la preuve de la gravité de
l'agression russe contre l'ukraine et
des conséquences innombrables que celle
ci entraîne en vérité vous l'avez dit
madame la ministre il s'agit bien d'un
événement historique pour l'europe dont
nous devons prendre conscience
aujourd'hui
mesureront en effet la révolution
mentale le changement d'ère que cet
événement constitue temps pour les
finlandais que pour les suédois pour les
premiers les finlandais c'est un
stigmates de la guerre froide qui
soudain s'efface pourtant cette
neutralité contraintes visait
précisément à survivre à la menace russe
le renoncement à une politique étrangère
pleinement indépendante cette fameuse
finlandisation ces sacrifices semble
donc aujourd'hui insuffisant face à une
russie jugés plus menaçante qu'aux pires
moments du rideau de fer en 2020 20% des
finlandais soutenaient l'adhésion à
l'otan ils étaient 76 % en mai 2022 les
autorités désignent qui avait tenté de
conserver une approche équilibrée
vis-à-vis de moscou tout ceci aura donc
été balayé par l'agression russe
loin d'aboutir à la finlandisation de
l'ukraine laventure de monsieur poutine
a précipité l'hôte anisation de la
finlande pour les suédois le séisme est
sans doute encore plus violent et
peut-être plus profond en paix depuis
1814 ce pays peut se féliciter d'avoir
échappé à toute invasion pendant de
longs siècles
et voici que vol soudain en éclat un
élément constitutif de l'identité
nationale fondée sur l'alliance étroite
de la neutralité d'un soutien sans
faille au multilatéralisme et d'une aide
massive aux pays en voie de
développement
la suède avait lié depuis longtemps son
destin à celui de la finlande en matière
de sécurité extérieure ils allaient
clair il était clair que dans cette
affaire de l'otan la suède allait
emboîter le pas à la phalange alors
qu'apporte cette adhésion aux deux pays
et réciproquement qu apporte l alliance
et de ce fait qu'elle et son apport
aussi pour nous les français
l'assurance stratégique que représente
l'article 5 du traité de l'atlantique
nord constitue évidemment la première
motivation des deux pays avec
l'agression russe la fameuse garantie de
sécurité est sortie des manuels de droit
international pour devenir plus concret
le plus précieux des remparts pour la
première fois depuis la fin de la guerre
froide
plusieurs pays européens se sentent
eux-mêmes directement menacés dans leur
existence par la russie les récentes
déclarations américaines et de
responsables de l'otan selon lesquelles
l'alliance défendrait je cite chaque
centimètre carré du territoire des pays
membres n'ont fait que renforcer la
valeur symbolique de cet article 5 du
point de vue de le temps il s'agit d'un
succès considérable on est passé en
moins de deux ans du constat d'une
organisation quasi mort cérébrale
malmené par le président américain a une
haute and attractive et revivifié
l'adhésion des deux pays dont la
neutralité paraissait intangible marque
ainsi une véritable résurrection
sur le plan concret ensuite l'apport à
notre sécurité collective n'est pas
négligeable bien au contraire les armées
de ces deux pays sont complètement
interopérable avec celles de l'otan au
delà des mécanismes de coopération que
vous avez rappelé madame la ministre ce
lien a été forgée dans l'épreuve par les
combats communs que nous avons menées
dans les balkans en afghanistan et en
irak au terme de cette évolution qui
s'est encore accélérée avec l'invasion
de l'ukraine la finlande et la suède
sont aujourd'hui et de loin les deux
pays les plus proches de notre alliance
il dispose aussi d'importantes capacités
sans revenir longuement sur ce point
qu'il suffise de rappeler que la
finlande touche déjà au fameux 2% du
produit intérieur brut consacré à la
défense seuil que la suède a promis
d'atteindre en 2028 la suède quant à
elle dispose une solide industrie
militaire et a récemment réintroduit le
service militaire obligatoire tandis que
la finlande pour sa part peu maudit
l'immobiliser jusqu'à 870000 réservistes
toutefois nous aurions tort de mesurer
l'apport que constitue l'adhésion de ces
deux pays en nous contentant les
additionner les uns aux autres les
milliards d'euros les équipements ou les
hommes tout comme nous aurions tort de
croire que ces chiffres suffisent à
assurer notre sécurité j'y reviendrai
dans une seconde d'un côté c'est
adhésion apporte en fait une profondeur
stratégique nouvelle qui renforcera la
posture de défense et de dissuasion du
flanc oriental de l'otan ceci crée de
nouveau dilemme stratégique pour la
russie et permettra certainement une
défense plus crédible des pays baltes
que nous avions visité récemment avec le
président du sénat d'un autre côté cet
événement nous fait entrer dans une
situation nouvelle nous obligeant à
redoubler de prudence
l'adhésion de la finlande offre à l'otan
1300 nouveaux kilomètres de frontière où
il faudra à la fois contré avec fermeté
et discernement les inévitables
provocation russe et éviter aussi tout
risque d' escalade
le fait qu'elle inc qui garde une
tradition de bon voisinage avec la
russie et à un intérêt évident à garder
la situation sous contrôle constituent
de notre point de vue un atout
indéniable
inversement il faut souligner qu'aucune
demande n'a été formulée en vue du
déploiement de forces ou d'équipement de
l'otan sur les territoires suédois ou
finlandais ces deux pays estimant eux
mêmes être en mesure de se défendre
je voudrais néanmoins
aborder deux points de vigilance très
important pour nous mêmes madame la
ministre tout d'abord et vous l'avez
évoqué le chantage exercé par la turquie
qui doit donner évidemment son accord à
cette adhésion à ces adhésions le
chantage exercé par la turquie qui
bloquaient le processus d'adhésion n'a
été surmontée
couprie de la signature d'un mémorandum
trilatérale
et celui ci peut interroger pour au
moins deux raisons premièrement la
finlande et la suède se sont engagés en
pas à empêcher les activités du pkk mais
aussi du pays y d'aidé ipg qui sont nos
alliés dans la coalition internationale
contre des ch en syrie elle promet aussi
de lever leur embargo sur la vente de
certaines armes à la turquie ce qui peut
poser problème
autre point d'attention et de vigilance
suède et finlande se sont engagés à
soutenir la participation de la turquie
aux initiatives de la psdc
une telle participation ne va pourtant
pas de soi étant donné l'attitude
actuelle de la turquie envers la grèce
et chypre comme l'a souligné le rapport
sur la boussole stratégique de nos
collègues ronan le gleut hélène conway
au delà d'un évident problème de
compatibilité de valeur il faut éviter
que les bénéfices de ce genre de
coopération ne s'avère déséquilibrée au
profit d'un pays qui en l'occurrence ne
respectent pas toujours les règles de
l'otan c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
aussi est il impératif de veiller à ce
que le temps ne s'aligne pas sur un
mémorandum qui par nature ne doit
pouvoir engager ni l'alliance ni les
alliés vous en avez pris l'engagement
madame la ministre et je vous en donne
acte
deuxième point de vigilance cette double
adhésion signifie certes un renforcement
de l'otan mais nous sommes en droit de
nous poser la question de quel temps
nous parlons premièrement l'entrée de la
suède et de la finlande pourrait avoir
des conséquences sur la politique de la
de la porte ouverte les candidats
actuels sont l'ukraine et on voit bien
le problème que pose cette demande la
géorgie et la bosnie herzégovine
ce sujet doit continuer à être abordé
avec courage et lucidité
chaque adhésion doit rester un processus
individuel lié à la mise à niveau de
l'appareil de défense mais aussi à la
situation politico-militaire de chaque
candidat
au delà et c'est un second point
d'attention le sommet de madrid a abouti
à une révision du concept stratégique de
l'otan avec une mention inédite du fait
que je cite les ambitions et les
politiques coercitives de la chine remet
en cause nos intérêts notre sécurité et
nos valeurs en outre le japon la corée
du sud et la nouvelle-zélande ont été
pour la première fois invités à assister
à un sommet de l'otan
nous pensons qu'à rebours de cette
évolution vers une alliance globale
l'entrée dans le temps de deux pays
membres de l'union européenne doit au
contraire est un levier pour renforcer
la dimension proprement européenne de
notre sécurité la suède et la finlande
se sont d'ailleurs engagés à renforcer
la coopération entre l'union européenne
et le temps ce dont nous nous félicitons
remarquons tout de même que ces deux
pays sont déjà en tant qu'etat membre de
l'union européenne couvert par la
garantie de sécurité de l'article 42 7
du traité de l'union européenne autant
dire que celle ci a encore beaucoup à
faire pour assurer sa crédibilité
dans le même ordre d'idées nous devons
oeuvrer au sein de l'otan pour que ce
nouvel essor profite au renforcement des
capacités de défense propre aux pays
européens
sous ses réserves la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées vous propose donc de
ratifié l'adhésion de le à l'otan de la
suède et de la finlande ces deux
démocraties qui partage pleinement nos
valeurs vous venez de le rappeler 18
pays de l'otan et plus dans les heures
qui viennent de précéder la belgique la
lituanie 18 pays le temps déjà ratifié
les protocoles nous avons encore
quelques inquiétudes du côté de la
turquie mais en attendant la fin du
processus de ratification
il serait prudent de se fit il serait
peu prudent de se fier aux déclarations
russes plus modéré qu il y a trois mois
sur ce sujet c'est pourquoi nous nous
félicitons que la france est proposée à
la suède et la finlande des mesures de
réassurance que vous venez d'exposer en
choisissant de rejoindre l'otan la suède
et la finlande ont fait un choix
historique qui crée une communauté de
destin encore plus étroite avec les
autres pays européens
au moment où nous devons opposer l'unité
et la fermeté à une agression
intolérable
l'entrée au sein de l'alliance
représente pour nous de la part de la
suède et de la finlande
et pour tous ceux qui soutiennent du
reste l'ukraine martyriser un apport
précieux temps en faveur de la paix que
de notre propre sécurité
je vous remercie monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
dans la suite de notre discussion
générale je vais donner la parole à
madame nicole duranton pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants avaient la
parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées dans le contexte de l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie lancé en février
2022 des demandes formelles d'adhésion
ont été des bosses déposé le 18 mai
auprès du secrétaire général de l'otan
par deux pays de l'union européenne
proche de l'alliance la finlande et la
suède c'est un moment historique
vous l'avez rappelé madame la ministre
l'otan et la suède partagent des valeurs
communes entretiennent un dialogue
politique ouvert et régulier et mène une
coopération pratique dans un large
éventail de domaines la coopération a
débuté en 1994 lorsque la suède a
rejoint le programme de partenariat pour
la paix sa première contribution une
opération dirigée par le temps remonte à
1995 lorsqu'elle à déployer un bataillon
en bosnie herzégovine depuis au kosovo
en libye en afghanistan
la suède s'est engagé aux côtés de
l'otan de ce compte de ce côté après
1947 la finlande a pu rester une
démocratie parlementaire et il n'y a pas
eu à intégrer le pacte de varsovie en
échange de ne pas rentrer dans le temps
et de refuser de bénéficier du plan
marshall dans les années 1950 on a ainsi
commencé à parler de finlandisation pour
désigner la neutralisation d'un pays
dans la sphère d'influencé d'une grande
puissance toutefois comme pour la suède
la coopération a débuté en 1994 la
finlande a participé aux exercices de
l'otan en bosnie herzégovine aux balkans
en afghanistan en géorgie en albanie et
en moldavie et en irak en 2017 elle a
créé dans sa capitale le centre
d'excellence européen pour la lutte
contre les menaces hybride est signé
l'accord-cadre cyber défense
historiquement l'otan a pleinement
respecter la politique de non-alignement
militaire de la suède et de la finlande
mais aujourd'hui le temps de la
finlandisation est dépassée voire
renverser le fait que ces deux pays ne
te demandent à rejoindre l'otan témoigne
de la gravité et du caractère inédit de
la situation en europe avec la guerre en
ukraine en tant que nation cela nous
oblige les pays se sentant menacée ne
veulent plus isolés se replier sur eux
mêmes mais au contraire s'intégrer dans
des structures plus grandes bien sûr
cela doit aussi se faire en cohérence
avec la construction de l'europe de la
défense une otan élargie et forte peut
tout à fait coexister avec l'europe de
la défense comme l'a rappelé hier lors
de son audition devant notre commission
notre ministre des armées sébastien
lecornu c'est une volonté forte de notre
président de la république
emmanuel macron l'europe s'étant
toujours construite durant des périodes
de crise nous avons en face de nous
toutes les occasion d'avancer sur les
questions de défense le 4 juillet à
l'issue du sommet de madrid les
pourparlers d'adhésion ont été menées à
bien au siège de l'organisation à
bruxelles le lendemain les alliés ont
signé les protocoles d'accession qui
doivent désormais être ratifié par les
30 pays membres de l'otan les deux pays
font partie des six partenaires
nouvelles opportunités il participe au
programme de transport aérien
stratégique sac et salissent de science
au service de la paix et de sécurité et
la mise en application de la résolution
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu sur les
femmes la paix et la sécurité
comportant à sa création 12 membres
l'otan s'est bien élargi huit fois
depuis 1949 pour accueillir 18 nouveaux
membres expliqué en détail le processus
d'adhésion peut paraître fastidieux mais
il a pris moins de deux ans pour la
macédoine du nord au vu de la situation
l'adhésion de ces deux pays devraient
vraisemblablement être encore plus
rapide en effet les différents critères
à respecter ne devrait pas poser de
problème
le secrétaire général de l'otan s'est
dit confiant sur les chances d'adhésion
de la finlande et de la suède mais les
deux pays sont tout de même ralenti dans
leur demande d'adhésion par deux
facteurs bloquants la turquie d'une part
la russie d'autre part après leur avoir
demandé de faire le nécessaire pour
extrader les membres du parti des
travailleurs kurdes sur leur territoire
en marge du sommet de madrid fin juin le
président turc erdogan a accusé
stockholm et haynes qui d'auberge pour
les terroristes du pkk ce lundi 18
juillet il a à nouveau menacé de geler
ses adhésions opérant un chantage à la
veille du sommet tripartite avec la
russie et l'iran à téhéran le ministre
des affaires étrangères turc a été
plutôt rassurant en reconnaissant que la
finlande était très respectueux des
inquiétudes du président erdogan en fait
la turquie semble vouloir négocier la
fin de l'embargo imposé sur ces drones
l'a dit moore poutine affiche aussi son
hostilité à cet élargissement de l'otan
dont il fustige les ambitions
impérialistes au plan géopolitique les
russes redoutent l'installation par
l'otan d'un arc nucléaire à leurs
frontières à ce jour
comme vous l'avez rappelé 18 membres ont
déjà ratifié les protocoles un tel
élargissement est conforme aux
stipulations de l'article 10 du traité
de l'atlantique-nord relatifs à la
politique de la porte ouverte soutenue
par la france au plan militaire
l'adhésion de la finlande et de la suède
permettra ainsi à l'alliance est donc à
la france de bénéficier du potentiel des
280 mille soldats 870000 réservistes
finlandais et du poids de l'industrie de
défense suédoise dans le cadre de leur
adhésion à l'otan la finlande et la
suède s'engage à maintenir un niveau
d'investissement militaire à hauteur de
2% de leur pib le bureau de la
planification de l'otan a établi que la
finlande contribuerait à hauteur de 24
millions d'euros et la suède à hauteur
de 50 millions d'euros au financement
commun annuelle de l'alliance en
conséquence la contribution de la france
diminuera une économie de plus de 5,4
millions d'euros pour le budget
militaire est presque un million d'euros
pour le budget civils selon l'estimation
préalable fait par la représentation
permanente française bien entendu le
groupe r des pays est favorable à ce
projet de loi autorisant la ratification
de ces deux protocoles je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue avait appelé le
président claude malhuret
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur président mes
chers collègues l'histoire du 20e siècle
fut celle la lutte à mort entre les
démocraties et les totalitarismes
parfois très près de la perdre nous
l'avons gagnée par deux fois la première
à la chute du mur de l'atlantique la 2e
à la chute du mur de berlin nous avions
cru cette victoire définitive le 21e
siècle nous apprend que nous nous
trompions le 24 février 2022 ne marquent
une rupture que pour ceux qui ne
l'avaient pas encore compris l'avion
russe n'est qu'un épisode
particulièrement sanguinaire du retour
de cette lutte mortels retour qui a
commencé à grozny et s'est poursuivie en
ossétie en abrasif en transnistrie en
syrie en libye aujourd'hui en ukraine et
en afrique demain en mer de chine ne
nous y trompons pas ce n'est pas la
russie qui va changer la donne avec son
pib égal à celui de l'espagne et malgré
ses rodomontades nucléaire c'est la
chine bientôt première puissance
mondiale qui scrutent attentivement
l'issue du conflit en europe pour fixer
sa stratégie face à taiwan et face au
monde démocratique
les américains le savent au moins de
plus obama les européens auraient aimé
conserver leurs illusions ils pensaient
certains par mercantilisme d'autre part
antiaméricanisme d'autres enfin par
lâcheté ou par naïveté que le bourreau
leur accorderait encore un instant
la sale guerre de poutine c'est atroce à
dire nous a ouvert des yeux victime du
piège de thucydide le tueur du kremlin
est allé trop loin trop tôt il pensait
diviser l'europe il l'a cimente
ridiculiser l'otan il la retrouve
humiliés les états unis il ressuscite
byden après le revers de kaboul
rallier les dictatures sous sa bannière
la chine s'inquiète de cette erreur
stratégique la turquie montre les dents
le kazakhstan refusé l'envoi de ses
soldats l'adhésion de la finlande et de
la suède à l'otan est un symbole majeur
de nos yeux enfin ouvert de même que les
sanctions enfin efficace l'aide
militaire conséquente à l'ukraine et la
mobilisation unanime de toutes les
démocraties la prise de conscience est
elle assez tardive c'est toujours le
point faible des démocraties croire en
2008 après la géorgie qu'on pouvait
continuer à être partenaire de la russie
renoncé à répondre aux attaques
chimiques dans la gutta en 2013 se
bornait à quelques sanctions lors de
l'annexion de la crimée en 2014 était la
porte ouverte aux rêves de conquête du
petit caïd de saint pétersbourg devenu
colonel du kgb puis dictateur puits
bouché
ne recommençons pas ses erreurs à ceux
qui espèrent le lâche soulagement d'une
négociation par dessus la tête des
ukrainiens il faut répondre que c'est
aux ukrainiens de décider et qu'ils ont
décidé de défendre jusqu'au bout leur
liberté est la nôtre à ceux qui
craignent d'humilier poutine il faut
rappeler que pendant des décennies ce
sont les peuples d'europe de l'est qui
ont été humiliés occupé colonisé par
l'union soviétique que c'est l'ukraine
qui est aujourd'hui humilié
massacrait est détruite que toute
solution autre que le retour de
l'ukraine dans ses frontières
antérieures à 2014 serait sa défaite
celle des démocraties et du droit
international elles préfigurerait
d'autres agressions d'autres conflits et
d'autres défaites elle signifierait pour
les alliés de l'occident la certitude
d'autres abandons à taïwan au
moyen-orient en afrique ou ailleurs et
pour les pays qui hésite elle serait la
tentation irrésistible regardez déjà les
votes à l'onu ne tomber du côté des
dictatures notre objectif doit être la
défaite de poutine
le deuxième point faible des démocraties
et celui du long terme face à une guerre
qui a fait que l'économie aggravent
l'inflation augmente les dépenses
d'énergie il faudra tenir quand la
mauvaise petite musique de la cinquième
colonne des extrémistes de droite et de
gauche
poutinien hier munichois aujourd'hui
renforcée par tous les trolls les bottes
et les trash médias viendra susurré que
la guerre coûte trop cher que tout n'est
pas noir ou blanc que ce sont nous les
agresseurs que ce n'est pas notre guerre
alors que bien sûr elle l'est n'en
déplaise à ceux qui ici ou à l'assemblée
s'apprête ont tu as eu à voter contre ce
texte de ratification
troisième défi la guerre a convaincu les
européens d'accepter enfin la boutonne
la boussole stratégique proposé par
emmanuel macron qui jusqu'à présent
prêcher dans le désert
parviendrons nous à ce réarmement et
combien de temps mettrons-nous et
comprendrons-nous enfin que c'est un
siècle d'affrontement des dictatures et
des démocraties qui se rallument que les
dictatures et les totalitarismes
aujourd'hui la russie demain la chine
portant me la guerre comme la nuée
l'orage et qu'il faut choisir son camp
prétendre échapper à ce cadre
géostratégique ou y occuper une position
de neutralité tout en comptant sur le
parapluie américain serait une
incompréhension des rapports de force
l'europe puissance ne se conçoit que
dans une alliance toujours plus étroite
avec les autres démocraties alliance qui
assurent notre sécurité depuis 1945 et
dans l'appartenance renforcée à
l'institution qui incarne cette alliance
depuis 1949 l'otan bienvenue à nos
frères finlandais et suédois
merci monsieur le président le donner la
parole au président roger karoutchi pour
le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
il ya quelques mois monsieur le
président à votre demande
je recevais le président finlandais
sauli niinisto
et à ma grande surprise pote très francs
alors que nous avions les notes des
rapports nous disant oh la la la
finlande ne veut pas bouger pour le
moment elle regarde comment s'arrange et
où
trouver en tout cas une voie de passage
avec la russie le président finlandais
me disait et j'ai immédiatement transmis
au président du sénat en lien avec le
quai d'orsay
qu'il avait trouvé lui conservateur
président de la république depuis 2012
un accord avec sa première ministre
social-démocrate première ministre
depuis 2019 pour dire nous voulons
adhérer à l'otan contrairement à tout ce
qui se disait dans la classe politique
finlandaise dans la classe politique
suédoise depuis des années
effectivement peut pas reprendre tout ce
qui a été dit
bien sûr
le groupe l'est républicain je rassure
tout le monde je suis sûr vous étiez
inquiet va voter ce projet de loi vous
vous sentez nous sentent inquiets
dire que c'est un énorme succès pour
l'otan oui
c'est un énorme succès d'avoir deux
états européens puissant on l'a redit
ayant vraiment de forces armées ayant
vraiment des consciences ayant un passé
par exemple quand on l'a rappelé la
suède
neutre depuis deux siècles depuis
bernadotte
la finlande malheureusement pour elle
finlande disait contre son propre avis
après la deuxième guerre et après
l'invasion soviétique de 1940 en carélie
mais c'est le résultat d'un échec quand
même
c'est quand même le résultat du fait que
l'agression russe en ukraine
a provoqué en europe de l'est un
mouvement sinon de terreur du moins de
très fortes inquiétudes
si les pays baltes si la pologne ont
adhéré par le passé à l'otan c'est bien
pour participer pour être protégé par
rapport aux géants russes voisins et
aujourd'hui la finlande et la suède se
disent ça n'est plus possible de
discuter de négocier de trouver des
voies de passage avec la russie nous
avons besoin du bouclier de l'otan le
présent cambon rappelait il ya deux
trois ans non seulement on disait l'otan
ce machin
quasi mort on se demandait même s'il
fallait pas y mettre un terme créer
autre chose on parlait beaucoup plus du
bouclier européen du modèle européen
d'une armée européenne de la capacité de
l'europe par elle même et puis
aujourd'hui
le réalisme l'a emporté et nous voilà
dans toute l'europe bien content d'avoir
les américains et les états comme la
finlande et la suède s'empresse de
revenir vers nous alors qu' il pourrait
dire bah déjà dans l'union européenne
avec l'article 42 7 nous avions cette
solidarité mais nous préférons avoir en
plus l'article 5 du parc de l'atlantique
nord il ya donc effectivement un premier
résultat à l'agression sauvage de
poutine en ukraine c'est le fait qu'il a
ressuscité la volonté européenne de
participer à l'otan et qu'il a
ressuscité en france le fait que toutes
les opinions publiques étaient très
divisés sur l'otan finalement font bloc
en se disant quand on voit ce qui se
passe en ukraine et bras on se retrouve
plutôt en accord avec le fait que
naturellement nous pouvons participer
tous ensemble à cette force sous quelle
autant alors on l'a dit je ne vais pas
être très long puisque les choses sont
claires pour nous
c'est une force supplémentaire
la finlande à 1300 km de frontière et
elle le sait elle a durement paix dans
le passé avec la russie poutine est un
peu imprévisible il faut quand même dire
les choses parce que en france ou
ailleurs madame la ministre au début de
cette année on nous affirmait que au
final n'y aurait pas d' invasion russe
de l'ukraine puis l'invasion est là et à
partir du moment où l'invasion et là les
gens réagissent avec émotion avec toutes
les tensions que ça veut dire et nous
sommes évidemment partie prenante
on l'a dit cette adhésion entraîne un
nouveau chantage du maître d'ankara
chantage sur le pkk chantage sur les
mouvements avec lesquels nous avons nous
avions des accords dans la lutte contre
des ch jusqu'où l'otan jusqu'où les pays
membres de l'otan doivent aller pour
satisfaire la turquie et empêcher la
turquie de bloquer l'adhésion de la
finlande et de la suède à l'otan c'est
un vrai enjeu j'ose espérer madame la
ministre que naturellement vous l'avez
dit ce n'était pas un engagement de
l'ensemble de l'europe et de l'ensemble
de l'otan mais seulement de la suède
enfin
quelle est l'étape suivante pour le
moment la turquie n'a pas donné d'accord
sur l'adhésion est ce que nous n'allons
pas avoir dans les derniers jours de
nouvelles demandes de nouveaux chantages
j'ai vu hier que le gouvernement turc
avait à nouveau à deux voies d'un côté
les durs qui disait on n'a pas obtenu
assez il faut obtenir plus pour accepter
l'adhésion de l'autre les diplomates qui
ont évidemment essayer d'enrobé tout ça
mais enfin ça veut dire quand même que
c'est vrai nous sommes contents que la
finlande et la suède adhérer à l'otan
mais c'est pas facile tous les jours de
gérer l'otan avec la turquie il ya donc
un problème permanent sur la vie sur
l'avenir de l'otan et puis les orateurs
précédents l'on dit
moi je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
avec
la chine m'enfin hier je voyais des non
pas des délibérations mais les annonces
faites par des organismes chinois certes
pas le gouvernement et par des
organismes chinois qui commençait à dire
taïwan ça n'est plus qu'une question de
semaines
sous-entendu bat la fère ukrainienne
finalement
semble dire que on peut peut-être à
avancer alors bien sûr les états unis
sont là la flotte américaine est là la
protection de taïwan et là mais
là encore madame la ministre et je
m'arrêterai par là
dans le fond
poutine non seulement à ressusciter by
donne mais il a ressuscité la volonté
d'hégémonie américaine parce que voilà
les états unis champions en europe
champion en ukraine avec une industrie
militaire capable de fournir à tous les
états qui dans l'inquiétude augmente
leurs crédits augmentent leurs budgets
militaires et qui donc vont passer des
commandes et l'industrie militaire
américaine va très bien s'en porter
et puis voilà les etats-unis qui en asie
nous disent oui français vous avez
toujours dit que vous aviez un modèle
indo pacifique et que vous avez la
nouvelle calédonie vous lis négocié avec
l'australie plus ou moins bien que vous
vouliez négocier avec les uns les autres
mais finalement est-ce que vous n'allez
pas être obligé de vous aligner sur la
position américaine par rapport à la
chine parce que dans l'ensemble mondial
bat à tout est lié poutine se rapproche
de la chine donc les etats-unis
soutiennent taiwan les etats-unis
soutiennent l'europe les états unis vous
pousse à rentrer à participer à l'otan
attention madame la ministre oui nous
sommes évidemment tous d'accord en
france pour soutenir l'ukraine oui
évidemment nous sommes tous d'accord
pour condamner la russie où évidemment
nous sommes tous d'accord peut-être pas
tous dire pour dire que l'adhésion de la
finlande et de la suède c'est une bonne
idée c'est pour protéger des nations
européennes qui peuvent en avoir besoin
et qu'ils ont intérêt à voir un bouclier
mais en même temps madame la ministre
moi j'ai entendu le président la
république parler de la boussole
stratégiques européennes de la
souveraineté de l'europe attention à ce
que la crainte la peur
l'invasion de l'ukraine la crainte de ce
qui peut se passer à taiwan ne fasse pas
finalement des états unis le seul pays
capable de fédérer par rapport à la
crainte par rapport aux tyrans par
rapport aux dictatures et par rapport au
fait de défendre les démocraties
l'europe doit exister davantage
l'europe doit imposer dans certains cas
sa vision moi je pense que vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs madame la ministre dans
plusieurs déclarations la boussole
stratégique la force de l'europe doit se
manifester
oui à l'adhésion de la suède et de la
finlande
mais oui aussi à ce que l'europe
conserve sa puissance sa force et ne
soit pas uniquement à la traîne des
autres
merci monsieur le président
donner la parole aux au président
guillaume gontard
pour le groupe
l'écologiste solidarité et territoires
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
nous examinons dans des conditions d'une
extrême d'une extraordinaire urgence
justifiée par un bouleversement
géopolitique tout aussi extraordinaire
la demande d'adhésion de la suède et de
la finlande à l'organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord
cela a été dit et redit jamais au regard
de la neutralité historique imposé ou
pas de ces deux pays nous n'aurions
imaginé la tenue d'un tel débat il ya
encore quelques mois cette volonté de la
suède et de la finlande de rejoindre
l'alliance atlantique mettant fin à des
siècles pour l'une des décennies pour
l'autre de neutralité militaire illustre
avec force le bouleversement
extraordinaire de l'ordre mondial
et des équilibres géopolitiques européen
provoquées par l'invasion l'invasion
pardon russe de l'ukraine
31 ans après la chute de l'urss l'otan a
brusquement et malheureusement retrouvé
sa raison d'être
ce retour de la puissance américaine aux
affaires européennes quelque peu
délaissé depuis le début de la
présidence obama est également assez
nouveau qui n'est pas sans interroger l
illustre en tout cas la faiblesse réelle
ou ressentie de l'union européenne à
assurer sa sécurité collective le
souhait de la finlande et la suède de
rejoindre l'otan témoigne de la
confiance toute relative que ceux des
pays porte à l'article 42 du traité de
l'union européenne qui garantit
l'entraînent militaire mutuelle entre
ses membres cela interroge sur
l'efficacité de l'action diplomatique de
la france où plus accessoirement sur l'
influence politique des écologistes pour
oeuvrer en faveur d'une défense
européenne collective je ne ferai pas
mystère des positions historiques de ma
famille politique qui a toujours milité
pour le développement d'une défense
européenne à même de renforcer
l'autonomie diplomatique et stratégique
du continent vis-à-vis du partenaire
étasunien je n'aurais pas imaginé ça a
été dit me retrouver un jour dans la
position de plaidé avec force pour un
élargissement de l'otan
mais comment pourrait-il en être
autrement comment alors que la russie a
grèce l'ukraine et menace la suède et la
finlande ne pas répondre favorablement à
leur demande souveraine et démocrates
démocratiquement concertée d'adhésion à
l'alliance comment pourrions nous
envoyer à la russie et au monde un tel
message de désunion et de ses blesse il
n'est pas acceptable de briser la
solidarité des pays occidentaux qui est
la seule voie possible pour permettre à
l'ukraine de sortir victorieuse de ce
conflit et ainsi rétablir la paix sur le
continent
en cohérence avec le soutien sans faille
apporté au peuple ukrainien par les
écologistes européens c'est tout
naturellement que nous soutiendrons la
demande de la suède et de la finlande de
rejoindre la sécurité collective
qu'apporte l'otan aux pays européens
c'est le prix de la défense de la
démocratie de la liberté et du droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes menacés
opportun aux faux aux frontières
orientale du continent comme l'a
excellemment montré le rapport de la
commission commis dans la plus grande
urgence qui me soit permis d'ailleurs de
saluer ici le professionnalisme
professionnalisme de notre
administration il n'y a aucune
difficulté juridique économique ou
militaire à intégrer ces deux pays qui
remplissent tous les critères fixés par
le traité fondateur de l'alliance si
dell donc à nos positions historiques je
formule le voeu je crois sincèrement que
l'intégration de nouveaux pays jusque là
profondément isolé à l'effort collectif
européen est une pierre supplémentaire à
la construction d'une défense collective
elle s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans une
épisode dans un épisode historique de
réarmement et de renforcement des
capacités de défense des pays de l'union
européenne au premier rang desquels
l'allemagne en effet seul paradoxe de la
période le regain d'intérêt de l'otan
n'est peut-être que conjoncturelles en
tout cas le renforcement de l'alliance
ne veut pas c'est que par le
renforcement des capacités propres des
pays européens objectif compatible avec
celui d'une europe de la défense c'est
l'objectif de la france rappelé avec
force lors du sommet de l'alliance des
28 29 et 30 juin dernier que de
renforcer la relation union européenne
otan et d'assister sur le renforcement
du pilier européen au sein de l'alliance
les écologistes soutiennent cette
position française
je conclurai donc mon propos par deux
préoccupations qui ont été rappelés par
plusieurs
de mes prédécesseurs le protocole
d'adhésion ne le prévoit pas mais
rappelons clairement cet élargissement
qui comportera désormais 1250 km de
frontière supplémentaires avec la sueur
la russie ne saurait se traduire par le
déploiement de forces de l'alliance en
finlande et en suède la situation est
suffisamment conflictuelles avec le
belize belligérants russe pour ne pas
ajouter inutilement de l'huile sur le
feu un dernier mot pour dénoncer le
chantage inacceptable de la turquie qui
demande à la su l extradition de 33
membres du pkk en échange la
ratification du présent traité nous
faisons confiance au royaume de suède au
regard des positions déjà exprimées pour
ne pas céder et en aucun cas céder au
chantage les kurdes qui n'ont de cesse
de nous protéger contre la menace du
terrorisme islamiste n'ont pas à être
les victimes collatérales de la guerre
en europe merci merci monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant donc président
pierre laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues nous engagerons
donc au pas de charge la discussion pour
valider l'adhésion de la république de
finlande et du royaume de suède à l'otan
le gouvernement a ajouté ce projet de
loi à l'ordre du jour le 16 juillet nous
votons cinq jours plus tard une
procédure exceptionnelle expéditive dans
un hémicycle peu garni pour une décision
portant de portée majeure dans le
contexte de guerre actuelle ce n'est ni
sérieux ni responsable on nous demande
de ratifier les adhésions ces deux pays
déjà validé au nom de la france au
sommet de l'otan le 28 juin sans aucun
débat approfondi des évaluations
parlementaire préalable sur la nouvelle
doctrine révisé de l'otan à madrid dans
laquelle ces adhésions s'inscrivent deux
fêtes l'agression inacceptable de la
russie contre l'ukraine et les crimes
qu'elle entraîne depuis ont ouvert une
nouvelle page dangereuse de l'histoire
des relations internationales parmi
toutes ces conséquences dangereuses
la paix du monde elle provoque
aujourd'hui le basculement historique de
pays ancré de longue date dans la
neutralité vers le ralliement une
logique du bloc militaire atlantiste au
moment même où celui ci durcit sa
logique agressive qui peut sérieusement
y voir une bonne nouvelle pour la
sécurité internationale
comme membre de l'union européenne la
suède et la finlande pouvait déjà faire
appel aux clauses d'assistance mutuelle
des traités européens
leurs armes et sont déjà intéropérables
avec celles de l'otan dans le cadre du
partenariat euro atlantique
plus que sécuritaire la décision est
donc politique et géostratégique
ce qui change c'est leur intégration
systémique dans un dispositif sous
commandement otanien autrement dit sous
commandement américain
seront ils mieux protégés où sommes-nous
en train de les transformer en première
ligne de front potentiel entre leçon
l'otan et la russie donnant ainsi comme
il est dit
dans la profondeur stratégique
à l'automne nous prétendons les protéger
quand nous les exposons encore plus au
danger d'autant que si l'installation de
bases militaires sur leur sol est
aujourd'hui écartée elle pourrait
advenir à tout moment à l'avenir ces
questions mériteraient un débat
approfondi car la politique d'extension
de l'otan loin d'être un facteur de paix
a déjà par deux fois au moins
directement contre contrecarrer
l'opportunité de travailler à de
nouvelles architectures de sécurité
collective paneuropéenne après la chute
du mur de berlin et la fin du pacte de
varsovie où un autre chemin était alors
possible et après la première guerre de
2014 quand les accords de mims ont
ouvert une voie laissée en jachère
aujourd'hui il escalade continue du côté
de la russie et du côté de l'otan
jusqu'où sous impulsion américaine la
doctrine révisé par l'otan à madrid
assume un tournant particulièrement
inquiétant elle va pousser un
surarmement massif dans toute l'europe
et renforcer la logique mondiale
d'affrontements de blocs militaires
quand les grands défis de sécurité
mondiales sont alimentaires énergétiques
climatiques sociaux des centaines de
milliards d'euros supplémentaires vont
être angles outil par les pays européens
membres de l'otan alors que dans les
dépenses militaires alors que l'otan
représente déjà plus de la moitié des
dépenses d'armement du monde trois fois
plus que la russie et la chine réunit
ses dépenses profiteront pour l'eau pour
au moins les deux tiers aux industries
d'armement américaines élargir l'otan
c'est accroître encore la tutelle
américaine sur l'europe et perdre un peu
plus la bataille de l'eau ne de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne la
doctrine stratégique de l'otan en dose
d'ailleurs pour la première fois
l'élargissement de ses objectifs à la
chine progresse envers l'objectif
américain d'une alliance militaire à
vocation mondiale tourné à la fois vers
l'europe l'asie et l'afrique
enfin comment ne pas dire notre
indignation devant le mémorandum signé
entre le dictateur maîtres chanteurs
redjep tayyip erdogan pour marchander
son appui à cette double adhésion la
manière dont l'alliance et notre
gouvernement minimise ce mémorandum de
la honte est scandaleuse les faits sont
là nous troquons contre le feu vert turc
l'extradition de démocrates kurdes pour
les livres et erdogan qui après une
parodie de justice les laissera pourrir
dans les prisons turques est-ce ainsi
que nous remercions les kurdes qui ont
versé leur sang pour combats pros dèche
l'hypocrisie qui consiste à prétendre
que ce mémorandum trilatérale n'engage
ni l'alliance ni la france no fake à 12
cas ajouté à l'indécence de la
validation des facto par la france de ce
deal indigne avec un dirigeant turquie
feu tenait sommet il ya deux jours avec
poutine et l'iranien ebrahim raïssi à
propos de la turquie je vous repose la
question madame la ministre à laquelle
vous n'avez pas répondu en commission
tout le monde craint une nouvelle
offensive contre les forces kurdes dans
le nord-est de la syrie des frappes
ciblées ont déjà eu lieu ces derniers
jours qu'attend la france pour réagir et
dénoncer ce nouveau coup de force le
chantage otaniens est-il le prix de ce
silence coupable
pour toutes ces raisons vous le
comprendrez nous allons nous opposer à
ce nouvel élargissement de l'otan tout
semble se résumer dans notre esprit à
préparer la guerre nous attendons pour
notre part à l'ouverture du débat urgent
sur la relance de voies nouvelles vers
la paix celle de l'indépendance et de
l'autonomie stratégique celle de
nouvelle architecture de sécurité
collective incluant la solution
politique des conflits intra européens
toujours non résolus je pense à chypre
et au balkan celle de la relance du
désarmement multilatéral
ces voies nouvelles pour une sécurité
humaine globale sont attendus dans le
monde entier par une majorité de pays du
monde qui refusent l'alignement dans la
logique des blocs pour son avenir madame
la ministre la france devrait écouter la
voix du monde pas seulement celle du
bloc atlantiste je vous remercie merci
messieurs président la parole est à
notre collègue philippe folliot pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président rapporteur de la
commission
mais chères et chers collègues il est
des moments où les peuples ont rendez
vous avec l'histoire avec leur histoire
il est des moments
particulièrement important pour les
démocraties avec la nécessité de prendre
en compte leur défense
ce qui s'est passé au moins de février
dernier avec
cette scandaleuse agression de l'ukraine
par la russie où pour la première fois
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale sur le
continent européen 1 et a agressé un
autre étang a eu un certain nombre de
conséquences
parmi ces conséquences c'est celle d'une
prise de conscience de la fragilité
de la sécurité collective tel que nous
l'avions imaginé tel que nous la
pensions j'ai à dire quasiment éternelle
sur le continent européen
et ceci a entraîné le fait pour
nos amis
finlandais et suédois cette prise de
conscience et cette volonté de rejoindre
l'otan somme toute monsieur poutine
malgré lui a sorti l'alliance de son
encéphale au g plat pour lui redonner
une forme d'attractivité et nous ne
pouvons que nous en réjouir
au regard de cette situation
bien entendu le groupe union centriste
apportera son soutien à ce projet de
ratification
il est pourtant important et essentiel
même de rappeler un certain nombre de
points je vais pas revenir sur ce qu'on
dit nombre de nos collègues au regard de
l'intérêt qu'il y aura pour l'alliance
de cette double adhésion sur les
conséquences au travers du fait de
l'importance
j'avais dur de l'outil militaro
industriel suédois de l'importance
de la finlande notamment au travers de
ses forces propres et réservistes 670
milles réservistes et est un chiffre
quand même et qui nous fait envie à
certains égards mais au delà de de
l'ensemble de ces de ces éléments je
crois que nous pouvons en profiter pour
réfléchir ensemble et se poser un
certain nombre de questions la première
c'est de constater que sont toutes
nos amis et partenaires et alliés
suédois et finlandais ont préféré la
protection de l'article 5 de l'otan à
celles de l'article 42 alinéa 7 du
traité de l'union européenne ceci doit
nous interpeller parce que au regard de
tout ce que nous avons dit depuis bien
longtemps sur les notions de sécurité
collective à l'échelle européenne et de
l'autonomie d'une forme de défense
européenne c'est malheureusement à
certains égards un cruel constat d'échec
par rapport à cela
bien entendu nous devons aussi continuer
à porter nos éléments de réflexion parce
que un des éléments de spécificité de
l'otan créée le 4 avril
1949 à washington
c'est quelque temps après la création de
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan
c'est-à-dire que pour la première fois
dans une organisation internationale
militaire à côté se trouve une
organisation démocratique
avec les parlementaires de tous les pays
membres et d'un certain nombre de pays
partenaires et du reste nos collègues
parlementaires
suédois et finlandais nous accompagnent
et son auprès de nous dans le cadre des
éléments de réflexion au sein de cette
assemblée parlementaire de l'otan donc
j'ai l'honneur d'être d'être membre mai
nous devons aussi
profité de l'occasion pour réfléchir sur
effectivement les enjeux relatives aux
nouvelles
candidatures qui lie à au sein de l'otan
il y en a trois à ce jour formellement
formaliser
la bosnie la géorgie et l'ukraine qui
est dans une situation un peu
particulière
il est clair que nous devons cndd et
chacun de ses agissements en fonction
des éléments d'opportunités et des
difficultés et des problématiques que
cela pourrait poser ensuite nous devons
aussi en profiter pour dire que si
l'alliance aujourd'hui est obnubilé par
ce conflit
de relative à l'ukraine et à la russie
nous ne devons pas pour autant oublier
les autres défis stratégiques qui
concerne à l'alliance il y à celui de la
question qui toujours pas résolue des
difficultés sur les balkans occidentaux
et nous y avons réfléchi à de multiples
reprises au sein de l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan mais aussi la
situation du sahel qui est un élément
d'interrogations mais pour lequel du
reste c'est une des spécificités de la
délégation française chaque fois de
rappeler ces enjeux relatives au sahel
au moyen orient en gros pour reprendre
une expression chère au président que
cambon le flanc sud qui ne doit pas être
oubliée par rapport par rapport à cela
mais si ces questions ce sont des
questions éminemment importante nous
devons pas non plus être dupes et être
naïf au regard d'un certain nombre de
considérations concernant l'otan c'est à
dire que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
travers de la turquie au travers qui
nous interpelle e par rapport au
processus de ratification et et aux
éléments qu'il pourrait y avoir et aux
mauvaises surprises que nous pourrions
avoir une ciné dans ce cadre là parce
que la séparation des pouvoirs
que nous revendiquons notre démocratie
en france est aussi vrai en turquie et
on pourrait craindre un certain nombre
de jeux de rôles entre guillemets entre
exécutif et législatif ne faisons pas de
procès d'intention
par rapport à cela mais pour autant
soyons lucides mais nous avons aussi un
certain nombre d'autres points et
d'autre un jeu relative au fait que les
américains aient repris la main et que
dans ce cadre là ne nous y trompons pas
leur objectif est de favoriser les
exportations sur étagère d'armement
notamment dans nombre de pays européens
et est européens et ceux ci donc nous
interpelle sur la stratégie européenne
en matière d'industrie de défense et la
nécessité de structurer celle ci est la
problématique du lien entre l'union
européenne et l'otan par rapport à ces
enjeux il y a aussi d'autres d'autres
questions qui seront un jour ou l'autre
des questions très prégnante il y a la
volonté de la part des américains aussi
d'élargir j'allais dire
le cadre de l'otan et se poser la
question de savoir s'ils sont toutes
celles ci ne devraient pas aller vers
des enjeux au niveau du pacifique je
crois que nous serons tous d'accord pour
dire que l'otan est une organisation
régionale relative atlantique nord
relatives à l'europe est relative à
cette partie du monde et qu'elle ne
saurait en aucun cas être entraînés dans
des enjeux dans des schémas qui
dépasserait le strict continent européen
je crois que c'est un élément important
parce que n'oublions pas que il y
aquelques quelques mois l'article que 4
de notre organisation donc de l'otan a
été sciemment violé par deux états
membres donc les états unis et la grande
bretagne pour ne pas les nommer
niveau donc de l'opération opus sans
parler du rôle trouble d'un allié
historique que nous avons qu'est
l'australie et que donc dans ce cadre là
il est important et essentiel aussi donc
d'avoir en mémoire l'ensemble de ces
enjeux donc pour toutes toutes ces
raisons c'est avec
lucidité mais aussi avec enthousiasme
parce que chaque fois que la famille des
démocraties à l'échelle européenne mais
se consolide pour travailler donc sur
ces enjeux de sécurité collective c'est
une bonne nouvelle et bien notre notre
groupe donc votre a favorablement à la
ratification donc de ce traité
d'adhésion de ce pays et donc nous leur
souhaitons bienvenue au sein de cette
famille de l'otan et tous ensemble nous
essaierons de faire ce qu'il faut pour
relever les défis de cette organisation
et les défis de sécurité collective dont
mais finalement nous nous rendons compte
qu'ils sont éminemment prégnant merci
merci
la parole à notre collègue andré
guillaume
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président la ministre
monsieur le président rapporteur de la
commission et chers collègues tout a été
dit sur les bénéfices incontestables
d'une adhésion de la suède de la
finlande au traité de l'atlantique nord
tout d'abord selon le vieil adage
l'union fait la force un passant de 30 à
32 membres l'otan augmentera fort
logiquement ses capacités militaires
les deux pays disposent en effet de
moyens significatifs notamment côté fait
landais et ça a été dit les ressources
humains de très conséquente côté suédois
on observe de stockholm que dispose
d'une industrie de défense compétitive
sur le plan stratégique clairement avec
la fin d'une neutralité historiquement
bien ancrée chez ces deux pays le flanc
oriental de défense du continent
européen s'ouvre et se trouverait
renforcée
j'ajouterai comme cela a été dit par le
président et madame la ministre que les
partenariats de défense déjà existantes
le temps et ces deux pays règlent la
question de l'interopérabilité
cette perspective est donc très positive
pour la sécurité collective du continent
européen ainsi que pour
l'approfondissement du concept euro
atlantique dans ces conditions mon
groupe est favorable au projet de loi
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
j'évoquais tout de même quelques
inquiétudes
les inquiétudes que nous sommes nombreux
à partager
au regard des dérives de vladimir
poutine la finlande et la suède souhaite
adhérer sans délai à l'otan j'en profite
madame la ministre pour saluer la
promptitude de la france et celle de
nombreux alliés qui se sont vite engagé
dans le processus de ratification
le souci on le sait ça a été dit viens
du côté de turcs comme nous certains
d'un cran sommes-nous certains qu'ankara
ratissera rapidement les accords ont été
conclus sont solides et compatible avec
les engagements du une partie des kurdes
qui luttent contre des ch
ensuite si la reconnaissance de l'otan
act et fin juin à madrid et eu de bonnes
choses sur le plan capacitaire elle
signifie aussi une forme d'organisation
de l'europe dans ce contexte comment
sincère la boussole sera gic porté par
l'union européenne et que la france a
défendu activement pendant sa présidence
européenne
sans faire concurrence à l'otan et dans
une parfaite complémentarité
l'union européenne doit conserver une
certaine autonomie interne de décision
stratégique la guerre en ukraine se
déroule à ses frontières et les défis
que le doit régler au sud au sahel en
particulier la concerne aussi
directement par leur impact en termes
vigato migratoires et sécuritaire en
outre le renforcement du pilier européen
au sein de l'otan ne doit pas conduire à
alimenter seulement l'industrie de
défense américaines au détriment de
l'industrie européenne aujourd'hui 60 %
des achats militaires européens provient
des états unis à cet égard je félicite
je me félicite que bruxelles conditionne
le projet d'acquisition conjointe de
matériel à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros aux principes d'achats des
producteurs d'acier en europe est sous
contrôle européen la fin de l'ère des
restrictions budgétaires en matière de
défense qu'implique le retour de l'otan
ne conduit pour conclure a déploré un
paradoxe à un moment où l'humanité court
de graves dangers climatiques est
jusqu'à envisager sa disparition que
nous savons que nous avons ici une
grande priorité devant nous nous voilà
amené à augmenter nos dépenses
militaires pour faire face aux régimes
autoritaires qui cherchent à affaiblir
nos démocraties ce qui m'apparaît comme
une ineptie le défi environnemental
exige des moyens colossaux faute de quoi
ce ne sera pas que la guerre mais une
terre meurtrie qui signera notre pays 4
malgré ces réserves la guerre en ukraine
et la posture martiale de la russie nous
oblige à considérer les agissements du
pilier européen de l'otan comme
incontournable mon groupe le
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen qui est donc favorable est
votre droit donc dans ce sens je vous
remercie merci chers que les geeks donné
la parole monsieur stéphane ravier pour
la réunion administrative des sénateurs
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
les paroles
monsieur non madame la ministre mes
chers collègues il nous est demandé de
ratifier l'accession de la république de
finlande et du royaume de suède à
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord la portant à 32 pays en 2022 une
question se pose dans quel but
aujourd'hui au sein de cette
organisation l'absence d'unité de vue
créer des conditions d'une impuissance
collective cela revient à réduire
l'autonomie des états souverains
européens en les soumettant aux
exigences américaines dont les intérêts
sont souvent divergents des nôtres
pendant ce temps la russie tente de
faire revenir dans son giron les
anciennes provinces soviétique la chine
fourbit ses armes contre taïwan et la
turquie pourtant membre de l'otan
entretient le mythe de l' empire ottoman
en soutenant l'invasion dans la province
arménienne indépendante d'arsac par
l'azerbaïdjan en occupant militairement
une partie de chypre adoptant une
attitude belliqueuse envers la grèce en
mairie j'ai c'est impérialisme
poursuivre leurs propres intérêts leur
propre destinée et il en va de même pour
le bloc nord américain qui trouve dans
la guerre actuelle en europe l'occasion
parfaite pour ne pas dire l'opportunité
d'élargir son emprise et de souder les
et alliés au sein de l'otan contre
l'ennemi russe
résultat les embargos à l'égard de la
russie favoriser les exportations des
produits américains notamment dans le
domaine énergétique et nous sommes
condamnés nous nous auto condamnons aux
pénuries et à l'inflation élargir l'otan
c'est réduire le monde au conflit entre
deux blocs anéantir la troisième voie et
des tampons entre les états unis et la
russie avec un tel scénario le risque de
conflit mondial est réel nous rendons
potentiellement belliqueux deux pays
culturellement habitués à la neutralité
en les forçant à intégrer le principe de
défense collective tout en rendant
progressivement inatteignable
l'unanimité nécessaire à l'action le
président de la république en 2019
l'avait pourtant affirmé l'otan est en
état de mort cérébrale à quoi bon dès
lors avoir intégré encore l'année
dernière la macédoine du nord et
intégrer la finlande et la suède
aujourd'hui cette organisation archaïque
issue de la guerre froide dessert nos
intérêts souverains nous a conduit à
baisser le budget de défense au point de
devoir nous en remettre de nous
soumettre au protectorat américain
l'autre l'otan sous l'égide les
américains c'est l'échec en afghanistan
et nos 90 valeureux soldats morts pour
l'honneur ce sont les bombardements de
civils et la guerre fratricide en serbie
c'est la déloyauté d'allier comme les
etats unis qui mettent sur écoute nos
dirigeants ou comme la turquie qui
brandit régulièrement la menace
migratoire et agressent nos bâtiments de
marine en méditerranée la pragmatique
allemagne ne croient plus dans le mythe
otanien elle a pris le tournant du
réarmement et investissent 100 milliards
pour moderniser son armée et possède
désormais un budget annuel de défense
deux fois supérieur au nôtre dans le
conflit russo ukrainien la vocation de
la france devrait être
pour retrouver sa tradition de non
alignement diplomatique de dialoguer
pour préserver l'espoir de paix dans cet
esprit je m'opposerai à l'élargissement
de l'otan comme je me refuse d'ouvrir la
porte à l'entrée de l'ukraine en son
sein je vous invite donc mes chers
collègues en faire de même afin de
retrouver notre indépendance notre
efficacité et notre stabilité
merci la parole est notre collègue jean
marc todeschini pour le groupe
socialiste
écologistes et républicains
holnon chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense chers collègues
la succession des événements récents
nous démontre qu'en matière de
géopolitique
il n'y a pas de certitude absolue
si l'histoire et la géographie peuvent
venir éclairer les analyses des
gouvernants et nécessités immédiates on
porte souvent les décisions ici le rôle
de notre chambre était en ciel nos
débats
doivent permettre d'éclairer celles et
ceux qui nous succéderont héron un jour
à prendre leur part pour la contre la
conduite de notre pays en ce sens nous
devons toujours nous efforcer d'aller
plus loin dans nos échanges que de leur
laisserait penser le simple résumé de
notre vote cela est d'autant plus
important sur un sujet comme celui qui
se présente aujourd'hui en séance
l'adhésion de la finlande de la suède à
l'étang à l'otan ne nous cachons pas
derrière de faux semblants les
nécessités de l'actualité font que le
vote de ce jour laisse peu de place au
doute
naturellement nous souhaitons que la
ratification définitive de ce protocole
d'adhésion ne soit pas à la fin
l'occasion d'un chantage à l'abandon de
nos alliés kurdes dans un contexte où le
dirigeant de la république fédérale de
russie s'est mué en assaillant
aux portes de l'union européenne
attaquants l'ukraine un pays souverain à
nos frontières il est évident que les
autres pays géographiquement proches
vont rechercher toutes les voix leur
permettant d'assurer la protection de
leurs populations et l'intégrité de leur
territoire
la première observation c'est que ce
sont bien les gouvernements de la suède
et de la finlande qui demandent à entrer
dans le cadre de l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord en cela les
gouvernements de ces deux pays
s'adapte à une nouvelle réalité
géopolitique imposé sous les demandes
suite à l'agression de la russie il
répond aussi à une demande interne de
leurs citoyens
jusqu'à alors historiquement attachée à
la neutralité et au nom d'un des nuls
ont singulièrement vis-à-vis de leurs
voisins russes
pour dire les choses clairement cette
demande n'est pas contrainte par les
états unis où un autre état occidental
elle ne répond pas non plus à une
stratégie d'encerclement de la russie
porté par les pays occidentaux
que ce soit au sein de l'otan ou de
l'union européenne
mais bel et bien par la mutation d'un
état voisin en un potentiel agresseurs
ayant lui-même démontré qu'il ne se
contentait plus de mots mais était
capable de passer à l'acte à tout moment
et sur simple décision de son président
absolue poutine en ce sens ou un autre
débat et a encore moins un état européen
ne saurait abandonner la suède et la
finlande à leur sort la solidarité ne
peut être autrement quand hier et assumé
cependant cette nécessaire solidarité ne
doit pas nous empêcher d'observer et de
questionner le sujet de l'adhésion à
l'otan 2022 de deux membres de l'union
européenne depuis 1995 en effet dans
notre analyse nous ne pouvons pas
masquer le fait que cette demande via
mettre en lumière une réelle faiblesse
de l'union européenne si l'alliance
atlantique est la première et principale
garantie de sécurité et du maintien de
la paix en europe si lorsque le danger
de la guerre se profile en europe le
réflexe instinctif de protection et de
se tourner vers l'otan alors cela veut
dire que l'union n'a pas encore réussi à
devenir ce que nous attendons d'elles
les faits le démontrent la défense
européenne on est à ses balbutiements
l'armée européenne n'existe pas en
dehors de quelques débats qui débouche
sur quelque dont une tentative
administrative d'un régiment
franco-allemand et de quelques essais
infructueux sur le terrain comme cela a
été la force takouba que le président de
la république nous avait vendu comme le
début visible de cette armée européenne
relayée ici même temps le premier
ministre et la ministre des armées la
coopération européenne en matière de
défense et concrètement la plupart du
temps issus d'accords directement pris
entre pays concernés à ce stade l'armée
européenne ressemble à une armée de
papier mais les plus beaux schémas avec
des flèches et des pointillés décidé
comme il faut voir des dons en face des
fonctions ne feront jamais une arme et
opérationnels sur le terrain capable de
conduire des missions et encore moins
dans le cadre d'un combat défensif à
haute intensité
il ne s'agit pas de jeter ici la pierre
les simplement de constater nous en
sommes réellement nous avons encore
beaucoup de travail avant que l'union
européenne soit en capacité de se
défendre seul en l'état les choses sont
claires la défense européenne n'existe
pas et l'armée européenne si elle existe
ce n'est qu'au sein de l'otan cette
année c'est armée n'est donc pas
seulement européenne mais inscrit dans
un cadre plus larges et étendues dans
lequel les états unis d'amérique ont un
rôle particulier entre membres éloignés
de la famille capitaine des types et
leaders économiques les etats unis eux
mêmes n'ont pas toujours la même
appréciation de séquelles autant souvent
ils aimeraient surtout d'avoir comme un
espace économique leur permettant de
vendre leur matériel de défense à des
partenaires privilégiés mais il faut
être le plus juste possible et aussi
constaté que il a par le drame syrien et
l'absence tragique de l'otan 2014 alors
que la france par la voix de son
président françois hollande était engagé
avec le peuple syrien les etats-unis ont
répondu présent aux côtés des européens
à chaque fois que cela s'est avéré
nécessaire dans notre histoire l'europe
a beaucoup progressé sur le fond depuis
et la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
néanmoins elle s'est peut être trop
contente et d'élargissement successifs
depuis la chute du mur de berlin
sans se reposer la question de son
projet de fonds et des moyens engagés
dans le domaine de la défense le retard
est gigantesque entre les intentions les
réalisations et les nécessités actuelles
et futures enfin cette double demande
d'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
nous oblige à questionner le
positionnement de l'union européenne
vis-à-vis de la russie la guerre en
ukraine se poursuit avec son lot de
haine de misère mais cette guerre la
russie ne pourra pas la remporter
l'union européenne a et aura toujours
des frontières communes avec ce pays qui
est aussi un membre à part entière de la
grande histoire de l'europe par delà le
vote de ce jour par delà les adhésions
de la finlande la suède à l'otan nous
devons aussi poser et répondre à la
question de l' équilibre de relations
avec la république fédérale de la rue de
russie dès lors qu'elle aura cesser son
agression et or a rappelé l'ensemble de
ses troupes dans son espace territorial
pour tout cela le groupe socialiste
soutient bien entendu la demande
d'adhésion de la république de finlande
et du royaume de suède où je vous
remercie
merci
de donner la parole notre collègue
joëlle garriaud-maylam pour le groupe
des républicains
le président
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues c'est un honneur mais surtout
une joie pour moi en tant que vice
présidente de l'assemblée parlementaire
de l'otan et présidente du groupe des
élus de droite et de centre-droit dans
cette assemblée de participer à ce débat
sur le projet de loi autorisant la
ratification du protocole au traité de
l'atlantique nord sur l'accession de la
finlande et de la suède à l'otan c'est
aussi une fierté que la france soit
parmi les premiers pays membres de
l'alliance euro-atlantique être en
mesure de le ratifier
dans des délais particulièrement courts
cela n'avait pas été le cas dans le
passé et la france par exemple avait été
l'avant dernier pays ratifié le projet
de loi relatif à l'adhésion de la
macédoine du nord à l'otan dont j'étais
le rapporte ici au sénat après un
processus
particulièrement long aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 19e états membres entamé une
procédure de ratification parlementaire
et je compte sur vous madame la ministre
pour pousser l'assemblée nationale
suivre l'exemple du sénat et à adopter
ce projet de loi le plus vite possible
le 18 mai dernier la suède et la
finlande déposé officiellement leur
demande d'adhésion dix jours plus tard à
l'occasion de la réunion de printemps en
lituanie de l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan le président du parlement de
finlande matti vanhanen et celui du
parlement de suède andreas north l'homme
était venu à vilnius nous demander de
soutenir leur candidature a le temps a
prouvé nous avait-il dit par plus de 80
% de leur population
nous parlementaires au temps présent les
avons assuré de notre total soutien et
de nos efforts pour que cette adhésion
soit ratifié dans les meilleurs délais
cette adhésion est une impérieuse
nécessité
car l'histoire vous le savez tous mes
chers collègues s'est accéléré et a pris
une tournure dramatique le 24 février
dernier avec l' attaque brutale et
injustifiable de lucre un pays souverain
indépendant et démocratique par une
russie violent tous les principes de
base la coopération internationale et
causant dévastation mort et souffrance
crise humanitaire et alimentaire
avec d'énormes répercussions à l'échelle
de la planète puisque l'onu estime à 255
millions les personnes pouvant souffrir
de famine dans le monde suite à cette
guerre il nous fallait être à la hauteur
de l'histoire et c'est une grande
satisfaction de voir que tous les pays
européens petit gros se sont retrouvés
pour s'engager dans l'aide l ukraine
bien que celle ci ne faisait pas partie
de l'otan et ne pouvait donc prétendre à
son aide directe sur le territoire cette
solidarité s'est affirmée lors du sommet
historique de madrid d'être en joie et
1er juillet dernier qui a vu l'unanimité
de nos pays membres en faveur de cette
adhésion
j'ai beaucoup entendu critiquer la
turquie mais je voudrais souligner ici
le travail positif des parlementaires
turcs membres de l'assemblée
parlementaire a le temps pour aider à
l'accord turc lors du sommet de madrid
mais comment aurions nous pu refuser
cette demande d'adhésion de la finlande
et de la suède deux pays qui partagent
un car nos valeurs démocratiques des
pays avec lesquels nous coopérons depuis
des décennies qui ont participé à nos
efforts de guerre dans les balkans
afghanistan si l'image sahel mali et
accueille des exercices militaires
autant sur leur territoire c'est un
honneur qu'ils nous font de vouloir
rejoindre notre alliance et c'est aussi
une démarche d'un grand réalisme alors
qu'ils étaient jusqu'à présent attaché
au plus confortable mais un peu utopique
principe de neutralité c'est aussi un
immense service qu'ils nous rendent dans
le cadre des nouveaux enjeux
stratégiques
et de la défense de la paix dans toute
la région pas seulement autour de la
baltique car c'est une dynamique
vertueuse et nous apporteront leur
expertise en termes de résilience mais
aussi leur capacité militaire cela a été
dit voltaire avait écrit que l'humanité
n'avait jamais connu la paix seulement d
entre eux de guerre avec l'otan alliance
qui a fait ses preuves en tant que
facteur de paix de stabilité cet
entre-deux guerres a duré plus de 60 dix
ans et notre devoir et pour les
générations futures d'éviter l'extension
du conflit russo ukrainien pour
maintenir la paix en europe avec la
finlande et la suède nous serons tous
plus forts et ce sera aussi un signal
fort vis-à-vis de l'agresseur russe cela
accroîtra notre défense collective
ce sera aussi protection pour ce pays
puisque l'article 5 cela a été rappelé
défini vous le savez une attaque contre
l'un de nos pays et une attaque dirigée
contre tous nos pays qui veut la guerre
prépare la guerre est un principe qui a
été une constante géopolitique et pour
conclure alors que la france cela a été
rappelé a toujours été d'une grande
prudence lorsqu'on parle d'élargissement
j'estime aussi à titre personnel que le
parlement a le devoir d'être un peu un
aiguillon du gouvernement surtout quand
il s'agit de la défense de nos peuples
et c'est pourquoi je voudrais dire
combien il me semble essentiel
d'essayer d'être d'aider à l'adhésion
d'un autre pays ami de la france la
géorgie à qui cette adhésion a été
promise depuis des décennies et qui
méritent d'y entrer par ses réformes et
parce que ce serait essentiel pour sa
sécurité comme je l'avais souligné dans
un rapport de 2014 à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan adopté à
l'unanimité
mais malheureusement non suivies au
sommet du pays de galles de 2014 merci
merci ma chère collègue
nous allons passer si vous le voulez
bien la discussion des articles
articles premiers
pas d'observations
demande d'inscription sur arte y
est
[Musique]
avis contraire
abstention
les abstentions
il est adopté
article 2
pas de demande à demandes d'explications
de vote je le soumets à votre
approbation
ceux qui sont pour manifeste en levant
la main
avec contraire
abstentions
il est adopté je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par la commission par le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes et par le groupe les
indépendants
république et territoires sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi avant procéder aux 24
il des demandes d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas il va donc être procédé
au scrutin public sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi autorisant la ratification
du protocole au traité de l'atlantique
nord sur l'accession de la république de
finlande et la ratification du protocole
au traité de l'atlantique mans
d'atlantique nord sur l'accession du
royaume de suède
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin
24 sur l'ensemble
du texte contre tenue de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique et dûment
notifié à la présidence nombre de
votants 348 nombre de suffrages exprimés
340 pour l'adoption
3,123 contre
17 le sénat a donc adopté
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues je vais maintenant levé
la séance notre prochaine séance aura
lieu le mardi 26 juillet 14h30 pour
l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi portant diverses
dispositions d'adaptation au droit de
l'union européenne en matière de
prévention la diffusion de contenus à
caractère terroriste en ligne
la séance est levée